Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This research group is known for their extraordinary
ideas, and this piece of work is, of course,
no exception. This paper is about time varying
textures. Have a look at these photographs
that were taken at a different time. And the
million dollar question is, can we simulate
how this texture would look if we were to
go forward in time? A texture weathering simulation,
if you will. The immediate answer is that
of course not.
However, in this piece of work, a single input
image is taken, and without any user interaction,
the algorithm attempts to understand how this
texture might have looked in the past. Now,
let's start out by addressing the elephant
in the room: this problem can obviously not
be solved in the general case for any image.
However, if we restrict our assumptions to
textures that contain a repetitive pattern,
then it is much more feasible to identify
the weathering patterns.
To achieve this, an age map is built where
the red regions show the parts that are assumed
to be weathered. You can see on the image
how these weathering patterns break up the
regularity. Leaning on the assumption that
if we go back in time, the regions marked
with red will recede, and if we go forward
in time, they will grow, we can write a really
cool weathering simulator that creates results
that look like wizardry.
Broken glass, cracks, age rings on a wooden
surface, you name it.
But we can also use this technique to transfer
weathering patterns from one image onto another.
Textures with multiple layers are also supported,
which means that it can handle images that
are given as a sum of a regular and irregular
patterns. The blue background is regular and
quite symmetric, but the "no parking" text
is lacking these regularities. And the amazing
thing is that the technique still works on
such cases.
The results are also demonstrated by putting
these weathered textures on 3D models so we
can see them all in their glory in our own
application.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!